so I'm going to talk about inference in
mathematics uh I'm a philosopher so this
will be from a philosopher's point of
view
um am I pressing the wrong thing ah so
um I'm going to talk about mathematics
and the general theory of inference
deductive inference in mathematics and
then non-deductive
inference um so the talk is about
inference in pure mathematics
um and mathematical inference can be is
is unusual in in several respects and
it's quite different uh from the the
talk is quite different from the ones
you heard this morning uh and earlier
today because mathematics is uh
mathematical objects for for a start
they seem to be abstract so numbers
functions sets uh geometric shapes and
so on that pure mathematics is
interested in um are not uh spatial
temporal they're not causal they don't
seem to be causal um therefore
mathematics is not a causal domain so
any kind of inference in pure
mathematics is not going to be uh causal
causal inference there are correlations
in mathematics but the standard picture
is that all the correlations are
necessary you know if certain spaces
have certain properties um well that's
just a necessary fact because it
couldn't be otherwise and deductive
reasoning uh proof plays an outsid role
in
mathematics so a general theory of
inference has to cover mathematics um as
well as other uh kinds of reasoning you
know scientific reasoning everyday
reasoning legal reasoning um and and so
on um so
soose let me give you uh a an example
from uh epistemology uh Alvin Goldman in
the late 1960s came up with with this
sort of shortlived um account of the uh
of knowledge a theory of knowledge which
stated that you know something if it's
true you believe it and you're causally
uh related to the fact in in the right
way um now this this theory was not
meant to apply to mathematics it didn't
apply to mathematics because mathematics
as I just said is not a causal domain um
the a theory of inference if it's going
to be suppose you want to come up with a
general theory of inference um should
you have that ambition it's going to
have to C cover mathematics which as I
said is is is unusual in these respects
um so just as the causal theory of
knowledge could never have been a fully
uh general account of knowledge a a
theory of inference which is just
limited to the um to causal inference or
to the physical case is not going to be
a complete uh theory of inference oh I
went the wrong way there okay or did I
go the right way went the right way okay
so like any other field mathematics um
exhibits two very broad types of
inference right so this is this just an
obvious point you can divided into
deductive inference where the conclusion
logically follows from the premises or
non-deductive inference where it doesn't
uh and this is just a non-deductive uh
inference is just a Catal category that
that um that anything that's not
deductive and I'm going to take a closer
look at each with a sort of Nod to my uh
research as prompted by the uh
organizers so what is deductive
inference um well premises necessitate
the conclusion necessarily if the
premises are true the conclusion also
has to be true the starting points if
the starting points are true then the
conclusion will have to be true uh and
our best theory of logical implication
or logical consequence adds something to
this uh to this necessitation idea um it
takes the necessitation to be true uh to
to hold in virtue of form so here's a
very simple example of what I mean by
that an is either American or Brazilian
A or B that's the form um Anna uh sorry
is not American not a therefore Anna is
Brazilian okay so there the premises um
if the premises are true the conclusion
has to be uh true but not just that it's
in virtue of of form any any argument
that has that form um is um also going
to be have that uh that property that
the premises well the truth of the
premises necessitates that of the um
conclusion so very natural thought is
that deductive inference is uh logical
implication now I've stated that very
roughly and that sort of breaks down
into two halves uh first the first half
is that when we infer
deductively we move from some premise to
or some premises to a conclusion that
these premises um logically imply okay
and that seems correct but the second so
I put a um a tick next to it but the
second half um the other direction
is uh not so clear in fact I think it
does not hold the second direction is
that if some premises logically imply a
conclusion we can deductively infer uh
the conclusion from the premises now
there's one sense in which that's true
because um you know if you can if you
can assume that you can you give us you
assume we have all the uh powers that we
we need to follow it a logical
implication then and it just it holds
but
um if you're not talking about idealized
versions of us but you know human beings
uh even just mildly idealized versions
um then that kind that that second
equation is not going to hold and more
importantly we need to sort of
distinguish U between application on the
one hand which is a relation between
statements um and that's not an
anthropocentric notion that's just what
holds um what holds a property that some
statements have um and uh collection of
statements have and others don't some
premises entail a conclusion or they do
not and there's inference which is
something that an agent performs and
which is anthropocentric by definition
even if we consider um idealized agents
so so here's a kind of general question
so what is what is logic well
implication is the realm of logic proper
right implication the relationship that
some statements have to to others
whereby they logically imply them like
in the an um the the Anna example um
that
uh that's what logic is interested in
logic is interested in implication and
what is that best theory of
implication by which by which I just
mean I use that interchangeably with
logical consequence well in this uh in
the book that Owen griffi and I uh wrote
and came out last year we argue that
there's a correct logic and that it's
highly um
infinitary okay so what what does that
mean well I'm not going to go into too
much detail but um one of the things it
means is that you can conjoin infinitely
many statements or disjoin them um
standard logic you can only conjoin or
disjoin finitely many um statements and
you can also in infinitary logic you can
also quantify over infinitely many
variables if you like uh unlike a
natural language such such as English
where sentences are a finite
length and this actually Builds on work
by alred tki and giler who's who's up
next um so the point here is that if you
once you understand the difference
between implication and inference
that sets you free it gives you it
enables you to give a account of logical
implication that isn't constrained by a
agents of course the only reason we got
interested in logic was because of uh
because we were able to perform
inferences but once you realize that
logic is not about what we can do but is
about what follows from what um then you
can for example um consider whether
logic is infinitary um which I believe
it is now the logic of mathematical
inference is can call that your Home
Logic if you
like uh Your Home Logic in a particular
context which you use for deductive
inference in that context is going to
have to be a sublogic of the correct
logic what whatever that is uh if you're
going to reason correctly
okay uh and a Home Logic is an epistemic
tool it it's going to be sort of more
much more down to earth uh it will might
for example be first order logic
otherwise known as predicate logic so
for those who don't know first logic has
names A B C so on it has variables XY Z
predicates fgh Boolean connectives such
as negation uh disjunction conjunction
and it has quantifiers for all that
exists and all its sentences are of
finite length and this is a very
standard logic um of course and your
Home Logic is going to depend on what
you're using it for right so you might
even use just propositional logic which
is just Boolean Boolean connectives
so much mathematical reasoning can in
fact be modeled by first order logic not
all of it but a lot of it can be modeled
uh and logicians are pretty good have
over the past Century come up with some
good pretty good models of mathematical
um inference using first order logic um
as that's to say as reasoning from first
order statable axioms by first order
logic appropriate rules to first order
statable theorems okay um so you got to
distinguish the logic that you use as a
epistemic tool for inference from the
the sort of correct logic which might be
um you know the the Home Logic might be
just the tip of the of the iceberg in a
particular
context okay now I want to move on to to
something else let's setting aside the
logic um talked about the logic in
mathematical inference in my overview of
uh mathematical inference um that I'm
giving you inference in mathematics how
should we characterize the
epistemology uh of deductive
mathematical inference you know what is
um what where what are axioms and where
do they come from and how do we know
them um a traditional picture here is
the ukian Paradigm okay it's inspired by
ukids elements from about 300 BC um and
it sort of held sway for more you know
couple of Millennia um the El being a
synthesis of ancient Greek geometry and
Mathematics more generally and very
roughly the idea is in mathematics what
do you do you start from self-evident
axioms via evidence preserving rules and
you thereby infer some theorems and you
you transfer the kind of evidence uh
this kind of maximal degree of evidence
that the axioms have down to the
theorems and as I said this is a very
this was a very prevalent picture of
mathematical reasoning from Aristotle um
at least from Aristotle who um from who
actually is bit before comes a bit
before uclid to the 17th century and and
Beyond uh and there's a kind of in the
17th century there's a kind of uclid
mania uh
a lot of people write books uh with a
titled you know the uid of this or the
elements of that they they want to um
any form of knowledge has to be recast
in this kind of ukian form for it to be
uh to be respectable you know um and
today UK clanism as a kind of Paradigm
of of mathematical um deductive
inference is on the way but it it had
some proponents even though the 20
Century and there's some people that you
might call
neans and so w Wrigley and I have
reconstructed and tried to assess this
ukian picture in this this book that's
going to come out next
month so what is this ukian Paradigm um
it can be expressed we think in these
seven principles slightly simplified
here that all axioms and theorems are
true all axioms are maximally evident uh
maximal evidence is preserved when you
reason from premisis to
conclusion there's a finiteness
condition the aims have got to be
finitely many uh the aims have to be
General propositions as an independence
condition that the axim have to be
independent each axm has to be
independent of the others that's to say
um if you had an axiom that you could
deduce uh from the others then it would
be a theorem not an axium then it it
loses his axima status um there's no
need to uh state it as an independent
axum and a completeness uh condition
which is a kind of slightly schematic
all truths of a certain kind can be
inferred from the accents if you if
you're atiz geometry and you've omitted
um and you're not able to prove a
particular fact that you already believe
about triangles say um then you need to
supplement your um axiim set you're
missing
something UK clanism the this this ukian
picture no longer holds in full
generality about mathematics today well
truth still holds we still think the our
aums um should be true of their intended
sub subject matter but truth here mostly
takes the the form of stipulative Truth
okay um think of the AXS of group Theory
the axm of group Theory Define what it
is to be a group so it's they are true
of groups but by kind of
definition by stipulation if you reject
if you think that one of the aims of
group Theory isn't true you've just s of
misunderstood what it is to be a group
The self-evidence principle doesn't
apply generally because in foundational
theories of mathematics such as set
theory there are some certainly some a
that are not
self-evident uh the flow principle fails
for sort of General uh General reasons
finess and generality usually apply and
Independence but Independence does not
apply generally um in standard aaic
systems uh they there may be some
dependency among the axioms uh for
example in in the standards that system
of set theory there is some some
dependence between the axioms because um
you know other criteria such as
Simplicity and ease of comparison
um are do it derata that kind of
override this this
Independence um do it derum and
completeness fails we now know uh for
various reasons it sort of depends on on
on the version of completeness that you
go for but if you go for the sort of
highest form of of completeness where
you can deduce either a proposition or
or its negation um in a kind of a system
other than a sort of very simple uh
axima system G's theorem G's
incompleteness theorem is going to tell
you that completeness is not going to
hold so what should replace idanis um
well the kind of move away from
idanis um introduces a couple of ideas
first the idea is instead of talking
about self-evidence think about
intrinsic
plausibility um or justification on a
conception if you if you think of um the
structure of the natural numbers you
have a certain conception of the natural
numbers then princip can seem um
plausible on that conception or not
likewise with sets um and this actually
and notice that this allows one to move
from that from self-evidence
to to Intrinsic plausibility or
justification on a conception uh
intrinsic plausibility on a conception I
should say um you are there thereby
allow for degrees of uh plausibility as
well and also extrinsic justification
should also be part of the mix so here
here's where you know pure mathematic
starts to look more like um
science um extrinsic justification can
be sort of divided into two broad
categories one is
regressive so this is analogous to the
kind of justification that's enjoyed by
a scientific postulate which predicts
the data you got some sort of
mathematical data in the mathematical
case um that could be very simple uh
claims you know simple arithmetic like 2
plus 3 5 it could be more sophisticated
um claims um and the idea is that an
axium gets to earn its keep by
predicting some of those these these
claims just as in those kind of
scientific cases but if this's
theoretical form of extrinsic
justification um also exists and takes
the following form that principles can
can enhance the Simplicity and economy
and unifying power of of the overall
Theory um and thereby I'll kind of
justify in that way
too
okay so um talked about mathematics and
general theory of inference and about
deductive inference and Mathematics
focusing on on the logic um and also on
the axim and what justifies the axim and
the kind of the old the old picture
versus the the new one that has
emerged uh I want to end by talking
about non-deductive inference in
mathematics okay so remember that
non-deductive inference is a casual
category that encompasses any sort of
inference that's not
deductive
so there are some broad categories here
for example enumerative induction
sometimes people just say induction when
you infer from all observed A's having
been B's in the very in very simple case
that all A's being B's from The observed
cases of A's being having some property
to the unobserved ones also having that
property all the inference of the best
explanation and very schematically
there's a body of established facts to
be
explained
and these facts can be a mixture of
observations and more theoretical claims
and among a range of explanations except
you should accept the best one that's
what inference of the best explanation
looks like and it's not deductive
okay caveat here about the explanation
having to be a good
one so what about mathematics I mean
mathematics how does mathematics rely on
non-deductive
reasoning well there's some obvious ways
in which it does so yeah I mean for a
start the choice of research project for
example um you should choose a research
project that's that's tractable either
for you a research project for you or or
your student um and by definition the
project has the research project you
haven't proved what you what you you
might want to prove uh therefore in the
absence of a proof you've got to kind of
make a judgment about whether it's a
tractable project or not there's also
what philosophers like to what
philosophers call testimonial knowledge
or justification so just like any other
sphere of um knowledge outside
mathematics firm as Last Theorem for
example approved by WS Taylor in the mid
1990s um is a you know 100 page paper uh
only experts in the field can read it
and understand it but you and I um know
that it's true because you know the
experts are kind of reliable community
and therefore that that knowledge can be
passed on to
us and and in fact most mathematical
knowledge is is of this kind you know
whether it's sophisticated claims of
proofs of of of such as the proof of
forma's Last Theorem or just simple ones
for the sort of lay mathematician uh who
knows Pythagoras's theorum because that
that teacher told them it was true or
the textbook told them it was
true uh there's also computer generated
computer assisted computer verified
proofs really this is just an example uh
of the former because you're your
um it's you're you're assuming that the
computer is the hardware the software is
is reliable when you're relying on it uh
to generate um some some result or to um
some calculation and so 21st century
mathematics will be severely hamstrung
by a strict in insistence on deductive
reasoning only I mean this would be a
kind of sort of proof
fanaticism um is there non-deductive
knowledge in mathematics okay by which I
mean knowledge of a mathematical
proposition without anyone having a
proof of it not just you know not even
WS uh and Taylor but but no one
whatsoever no computer haven't come up
with it um so I think I take the the
sort of radical view uh that you can um
know a proposition without anyone having
proved it um so mathematicians don't
like this at all in fact mathematicians
use the word word no in a mathematical
context synonymously with it it's been
proved uh we have proved so you know we'
we've known since 2002 than such and
such because someone proved it in 2002
but is that right so take the an example
of uh from number Theory go goldb
goldbas
conjecture uh or the example of
primality testing where you test the uh
whether a number is prime and then you
know you can uh quickly convince
yourself with probability that with
probability 1 minus Epsilon where
Epsilon is really tiny that it is prime
so gobas conjecture states that every
even number is a sum of two primes every
even number bigger than
two uh so there's a lot of enumerative
evidence behind it four * 10 to the 18
cases have been have been tested there's
also evidence that the number of ways of
writing an even number as a sum of twoe
primes
grows uh with that number not in a kind
of linear or strict way but it as an
overall increasing Trend there Pro some
very slightly weaker theorems there's
heuristic arguments about the
distribution of the
primes that don't prove but suggest that
the argument is true that the um gobas
conjecture is true and they're also
analoges of gobas conjecture that hold
in random models of the primes so you so
the the probability that a number n is
prime is one over log
n um and uh if you if you generate
sequences of numbers with uh with that
probability that's to say the number n
appears on the list with probability one
/ n uh you get a kind of prime like
sequence uh and then you can have an
analog of gobas conjecture for that and
you know a version of gobas conjecture
holds for for with with probability one
for for these sequences it doesn't prove
gobas conjecture but it but if if uh but
it does tell you that
what the the class of those sequences
looks like um also you could come up
with sort of philosophical arguments to
diffuse objections to the this kind of
idea that you can know mathematical
claims without proof and one such
argument is based on philosophical
analysis of knowledge so I mentioned one
before the causal Theory um and as I
said that that one doesn't apply to
mathematics or to put it positively um
it doesn't rule out non-deductive
knowledge of mathematics either
and if you look at the kind of these
philosophical analysis of knowledge the
things that have got some sort of
traction in the literature over the last
sort of 50 years that 60 years that
philosophers have been thinking about uh
this in in in a little detail of course
they did think about it before U but
they sort of fall into two camps either
they don't apply to
mathematics um like the causal Theory or
if they do they allow non-deductive
knowledge or mathematics for example the
classic um case of knowledge being
justified true
belief no you can have non deductive
justification as in the case of cobas
conjecture and actually if you think
about it there's sort of non-deductive
reasoning that's at the heart of
deduction because as I said earlier axim
are at least in part extrinsically
Justified and this is a form of
non-deductive justification right if you
if you um if you believe something in
part because it has some nice
implications that you already believe
then you're not deducing it from some
axioms um that that that form of
justification is
non-deductive and so abandoning this
ukian picture helps undermine the sort
of specialness of deductive reasoning if
there's some sort of non deductive
justification behind some of the axioms
then the kind of what's special about um
deductive reasoning has been has been
undermined another way in which there
sort of non-deductive reasoning at the
heart of deduction is that
mathematicians rarely give full proofs
right especially expert mathematicians
they tend to give proof
sketches and so your confidence that a
proof sketch can be elaborated into full
dress proof where does that come from if
you give a proof
sketch um where does it where does your
confidence come from what does it depend
on um that it can actually be turned
into a fullprof well just kind
of your your knowledge that this has
worked in the past or that steps of the
kind of this size actually C if you
spelled them out would actually would
actually be valid and so on so that's
that's that's Justified non deductively
that's just from your your experience as
a
mathematician so let me summarize the
four things that I I've told you in my
overview of inference in
mathematics any general theory of
inference should you want to um try and
come up with one has to cover
mathematics as well which is unusual in
several
ways the second thing
is that deductive inference isn't the
same as logical implication I think
deductive inference to be something an
agent does logical implication to be a
relation between
statements and I think and you don't
have to buy this but I think the latter
is this highly highly
infinit the third point was that ukian
Paradigm no longer applies wholesale to
mathematics a kind of a different
picture of mathematical deductive
mathematical justification is now much
more
current and my fourth point is that was
that non-deductive reasoning is
prevalent in mathematics and is in
perfectly good standing thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you uh thanks this is a really
interesting talk I was curious just
because you characterizes as ukan
program do you think that there's a
essential component of diagrammatic
reasoning that's a part of I mean at
least as uid originally did it is that
something that's important because
there's some people who I think want to
characterize that as possibly not being
something you can regiment in first
order of logic So yeah thank you that's
a really good question yeah so um the
ukian Paradigm or the UK ukan
foundationalism as I described it didn't
say anything about about diagrams uh but
ukl of course in the elements
relies U um very much relies on spatial
reasoning and um on D diagrams um
diagrammatic uh reasoning di you can't
really be convinced of many of the
proposition unless you draw a diagram
for for yourself or see it on the page
and and uclid was criticized for that in
you know uh in the 19th century and the
late 19th century especially as kind of
modern logic started to be developed um
people realized that there were all
sorts of gaps in in in his reasoning so
a kind of a new ideal for mathematical
reasoning was born whereby the steps and
mathematical reasoning aren't just um
are actually logical deductively valid
but and do not rely on on diagrammatic
reasoning in any kind um but I think I
think the ukian the way I wanted to uh
characterize ukian foundationalism was
broader than that I think that's a very
narrow way and a very kind of relatively
Modern Way of characterizing
mathematical
reasoning um if you want to take in
mathematic the history you know much
broader sweep of mathematics and and
understand why the U ukian picture had
was so important and was so do prevalent
for so many centuries I think you have
to allow um steps in mathematical
reasoning that are uh that could be
guided by spatial intuition that are not
strictly logical um it's when I describe
mathematical inference the um the dedu
deductive inference that that's a kind
of a modern a more much more modern way
of thinking about
it
I I would like should we move to T and
we can continue
asking our best stay time later in the
day so thank you thanks
[Applause]
for